bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous ce
matin en direct sur arte france alors on
voit que les manifestants libanais se
s'organisent pour exprimer leur colère
face au gouvernement et cela malgré les
mesures de restriction le confinement
quelle est la situation des jours et qui
m'ont appelé
après avoir marqué une pause depuis deux
mois et demi à cause du confinement des
milieux très strictes qui sont observés
au liban est ainsi parce que le
mouvement c'était un petit peu
essoufflée la contestation a repris vie
à l'occasion de la reprise aussi du
travail législatif du parlement après
une interruption depuis 2010 la
mobilisation qui s'est produite mardi
elle était celle de l'ict quelques
visuels de maturité dans les grandes
villes mais cela montre que les raisons
objectives qui ont touché les libanais à
descendre dans la rue
les 17 autres cadres dernier existe
toujours à savoir une cuisine est
financière et économique sans précédent
plus de 50 % de la population est tombé
sous le seuil de pauvreté
le pouvoir d'achat ainsi rod à vide à la
livre libanaise mais le national a perdu
100 % de sa valeur face au dollar les
prix ont plus que doublé
donc il y a un tas de raisons qui tous
les libanais à redescendre dans la rue
et a réclamé des mesures de réformes
sérieuses au gouvernement et à la classe
politique qui est accusé de corruption
et de dilapidation de pillage des
caisses de l'état de l'adedy la dette
atteint 92 milliards de dollars
c'est-à-dire 170% du pib
d'ailleurs le liban à se placer en
défaut de paiement et a annoncé qu'il ne
rembourserait pas sa dette et essaye de
négocier une restructuration est un
événement un échelonnement de québec
et s'agissant des mesures prises
ce par le gouvernement pour faire face à
la crise sanitaire mais aussi à la 6e'
de l'économie comment ces mesures les
libanais réagissent face à ces mesures
sur le plan de la riposte de la réponse
à la propagation des taureaux navires us
il y avait une unanimité en revivant
toutes tendances politiques confondues
sur une efficacité des actions prises
par le gouvernement qui ont réussi à
empêcher l'explosion de l'épidémie au
liban nous sommes à 7 681 cas 21 décès
depuis plusieurs jours depuis plusieurs
jours le nombre de cas confirmés est en
nette diminution cinq arrières les
mesures sont efficaces et tout le monde
le reconnaît y compris le hamas
l'organisation mondiale de la santé le
liban va probablement prolonger de deux
semaines
le compliment très strictes qui est
observé depuis le 15 mars
les écoles et les universités avaient
fermé dès le 1er marche donc quelque
part le liban à celle ci est pris très
tôt pour essayer d'empêcher la
propagation du virus
il ya une mesure sur laquelle on
souhaiterait vous entendre c'est la
légalisation du cannabis
le liban qui devient donc le premier
pays du monde à rabat à légaliser le
cannabis c'est un secteur qui pèse lourd
selon les estimations dans l'économie
véritablement le cannabis peut sauver
l'économie le liban selon les nations
unies est le troisième producteur de
drogue au monde de cannabis de chanvre
indien
bien que cette culture soit illégal dans
la plaine orientale de la bekaa des
milliers de milliers d'hectares sont
plantés tous les ans malgré les mesures
d'éradication de cette culture prises
par l'armée et par les forces de
sécurité mais cela existe
alors avec ses petits économiques sont
prêts
c'est dans l'ue et parlement a adopté
cette loi mardi qui légalise la culture
de cannabis et cela malgré une position
de chef de la d'ailleurs la culture de
cette plante se fait dans les fiefs des
chefs de là dans la plaine orientale de
la bekaa une opposition de changement
qui a surpris les observateurs puisque
ma proposition de loi a été présenté par
son allié chiite et le président du
parlement nabih berri
cette mesure ne va pas sauver l'économie
parce que les besoins sont immenses mais
elle pourrait contribuer à renflouer les
caisses du trésor à faire rentrer de
dollars au liban car en plus de la crise
économique nous avons une pénurie de
dollars les réserves de la banque
centrale sont à vue d'oeil et le liban
dans quelques mois n'aura plus les
moyens d'importer les besoins
élémentaires de sa population
donc il ne suffit pas de légaliser la
plantation du cannabis pour régler la
crise économique mais certainement que
cette mesure pourrait permettre
d'injecter de l'argent frais dans
l'économie libanaise
merci beaucoup pas les haqqanis et je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste
spécialiste du monde arabe